Julia's revenue is R of T thousand
dollars per month where t is the month
of the year julia had made three
thousand dollars in the first month of
the year
what does three plus the definite
integral from one to five of our F T DT
equals 19 mean and we have some choices
so like always pause the video and see
if you can work through it
alright now let's work through this
together so they tell us that she made
three thousand dollars in the first
month and we also see this three here so
that's interesting maybe there this they
represent the same thing we don't know
for sure yet but let's look at this
definite integral the definite integral
from 1 to 5 of R of T DT this is the
area under this rate curve R of T is the
rate at which Julia makes revenue on a
monthly basis so if you take the area
under that rate curve that's going to
give you the net change in revenue from
month 1 to month 5 how much that
increased and so if you add that to the
amount that she made in month 1 well
that tells you the total she makes from
essentially time zero all the way to
month five and they're saying that is
equal to 19 so let's see which of these
choices are consistent with that Julia
made an additional 19 thousand dollars
between months 1 and 5 choice a would be
correct if you didn't see this 3 over
here because just the definite integral
is the additional between months 1 and 5
but that's not what this expression says
it says 3 plus this is equal to 19 if it
said Julia made an additional $16,000
well then that would make sense cuz you
could subtract 3 from both sides and
you'd get that result but that's not
what they're saying Julia made an
average of 19 thousand dollars per month
well once again that's also not right
because we just said from from the
beginning from time zero all the way
until the fifth month she made a total
of $19,000 not the average per month is
19,000 Julia made $19,000 in the fifth
month once again this is not just saying
what happened in the fifth month this is
saying we have the three thousand
dollars from the first month and then we
have the additional from month between
months one and months
so that's not that so this better be our
choice by the end of the fifth month
julia had made a total of $19,000 yes
that is correct
she made three thousand and month one
and then as we go between month one to
the end of month five to the end of the
fifth month she has made a total of
$19,000 let's do another one of these so
here we're told the function K of T
gives the amount of ketchup in kilograms
produced in a sauce factory by time in
hours on a given day so this is really
quantity as a function of time it isn't
rate what does the definitely go from
zero to four of K prime of T DT
represented once again pause the video
and see if you can work through it well
K if T is the amount of ketchup as a
function of time so K prime of T that's
going to be the rate at which our amount
of ketchup is changing as a function of
time but once again when you're taking
the area under the rate curve that tells
you the net change in the original
quantity in the amount of ketchup and
it's the net change between time 0 and
time 4 so let's see which of these
choices match up to that the average
rate of change of the ketchup production
over the first 4 hours no that does not
tell us the average rate of change
there's other ways to calculate that the
time it takes to produce four kilograms
of ketchup
so does this represent the time it takes
to represent four kilograms of ketchup
no this four is the time right over here
this is gonna tell you how much ketchup
gets produced from time 0 to time for
the instantaneous rate of production at
t equals four now this would be K prime
of four that's not what this integral
represents the amount of ketchup
produced over the first four hours yep
that is exactly right